Speaker 1: Let's go to Bert from New
Jersey. Bert from New Jersey, Welcome to
the program. What's on your mind today?
Speaker 2: Hey, David. Hear me okay?
Yeah. Okay. Awesome. Calling a lot
about economic issues. I promise I'll call them,
but other things. But couple more to get off my
chest. Sure. You hear a compromise a lot from
the right about Trump, where they'll say, like,
you know, I don't like him as a person. I don't
disagree with his policies. Right. Right. I think
a lot of that comes from people on the left tend
to criticize him a little too much. I think that
filters out the criticism and it doesn't make its
way to his policies enough. Right. And I'll give
you an example of one that I think you agree with
me on, for example, like the people on policy.
Right. Yes. We can now look back at that and we
can say that was just an abysmal, terrible policy.
You know, you could say is the greatest
form of socialism ever implemented. We're
just shoveling money at people like crazy.
Speaker 1: Well, hold on a second. So let's
let's see if we can break that down a little bit.
So when you say we were shoveling, are you talking
specifically about the business people aspect
or are you talking about the COVID stimulus more
broadly where money was just sent to people?
Speaker 2: Ask. Good question and clarify.
I'm talking about the business side of things.
Speaker 1: Okay. The problem for me for the PGP
program was not that you were just giving
businesses money. The problem for me was
that there wasn't enough oversight. There
was tons of fraud, and it ended up being a
horrible slush fund. That was my problem with it.
Speaker 2: Right. But I think the policy around it
was garbage. And here's why. I don't if you took
people into your business or not. I mean, I did my
technology startup and it was my job to go out
and administer that PGP law. Yep. So I find the
paperwork and all the things. I was shocked at how
little there was to qualify. All you had to do is
check a box that says, Yes, my business has been
negatively affected by COVID. Unless you're in the
business of selling toilet paper or making coffee
filters, who's who's not going to check that box?
Speaker 1: Right. Yeah. And listen, I decided
not to take the money. I later learned that
there were other people in my cohort who who did
take some of that money. It is true that the IRS
is heavily focusing on now auditing people who
fraudulently took money. I feel fine. I mean,
listen, I get it. There was government money
out there for the taking. I don't regret not
taking it. I mean, we everybody was home watching
shows. We had a really great year that year. Like,
it would have just been wrong for me to
take it. But your point is absolutely
correct. It was too easy to get that money.
Speaker 2: Right. And and, you know,
Tom Brady got $1,000,000 loan like twice
government to bail Tom Brady's company
out. Right. Just one example. In my circle,
the common talk about was, hey, this is free
money. Go out and get it right when you need
it to prove you needed it. So my question is,
now that we can look back at this. Why
is that? It sounds like I'm criticizing
the right. I'm actually more criticized on the
left. Like, why isn't this being talked about?
This is a terrible policy that, you know, cost
inflation. I can go into all the things that
happened here. Why isn't this being brought up?
Speaker 1: Well, I think the left has to criticize
both Trump policy and Trump sort of like tone and
the non policy stuff. I think for a lot of people,
the reality is burnt because of attention
spans and so many other different factors,
it's much easier to remind people about. You know,
Trump believed everything Putin told him and he
believed everything Kim Jong un told him. And he
drew on a marker with a he drew with a marker on
the hurricane map. And he wasn't sure why we
couldn't nuke Europe. And a lot of that stuff
is much easier to communicate quickly than the
policy stuff. But I agree with you completely.
I think the other aspect on Trump and policy is
he also didn't do that much because so many of
the things he said he was going to do obviously
weren't going to happen. So, for example, the big
criticism on Trump, on the Israeli-Palestinian
conflict is he promised to solve it within a
year and they didn't. And the one thing he
did moving the the embassy to Jerusalem was
actually counterproductive. Right. But on a lot of
these things, Trump didn't actually do anything.
Speaker 2: Right. Right now, absolutely.
Everything I think about, too, is like,
what if the roles were reversed here? What if
this was Obama right? What would a right be
saying about this? This would be like Benghazi
in Benghazi to point out there be committees
and be investigations. How would you like
this? More taxpayer money to go to fraud,
Right. None of that seems to be happening.
Speaker 1: Oh, they'd be demanding that
Obama be put in prison if he had overseen
BP. There's no doubt about that. Burton,
good points and well-made. I appreciate it.
Speaker 2: Thank you, David.
Speaker 1: All right, Bert from New
Jersey. Excellent, excellent stuff